man sollte auch auf jeden fall auf die
veränderungen der ausstrahlung der
person achten ob sich vielleicht
glücklicher ist oder einfach mehr
lächeln also wenn eine person
glücklicher ist als sonst ist das ist
ein indiz für einen seitensprung
herbstkonzerte ich bin heute wieder
zurück für euch mit neuen fremdgeht
tipps vom baby leute ihr habt richtig
gehört hier wird es schon mal ein video
gemacht indem ich fremd tipps von baby
beleuchtet habe die kommentiert habe da
ging es darum wie man verheimlicht dass
man selbst fremd geht und ich weiß auch
nicht wie bier auf dinge dann gekommen
ist darüber video zu machen
lustigerweise gibt es aber auch genau
die andere seite von baby nämlich ein
video in dem sie tipps geben wie man
erkennt dass der eigene freund würde die
eigene freundin fremdgeht und das
schauen wir uns heute abend ihr fehlt
das originalvideo da beschreiben heute
und wie ihr vielleicht wisst ist mir bei
diesen reactions auch wichtig fair zu
sein zu den leuten man muss dazu sagen
dieses video ist schon über acht jahre
alt höchstwahrscheinlich also können wir
das nicht eins zu eins auf die heutige
baby übertragen ich persönlich bin ganz
froh dass mich vor acht jahren jemand
gefilmt hat also wir nehmen das ganze
mit tumoren wir fangen jetzt an leute
let's go
hallo dann gebe ich euch ein paar tipps
wer einen seitensprung ihres partners
erkennen können
okay ganz gute kommentare geschaut aber
die duisburger vor zwei jahren sucht ex
und nun fragt man sich von wem ist ihr
kind bruder till war sollte ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen früher vor zwei drei
jahren war ich ein bisschen mehr so so
ab zeitweilig noch ein bisschen mehr so
nett und habe heute mehr geht ist
heutzutage wichtig sind erwachsener und
will einfach mit nicht dass ich
irgendwann wegen meinen videos schlecht
fühlt also muss ich sagen ja ja ok ok ja
also an sich ein guter tipp dass man mit
der person redet selbst wahrscheinlich
an sich nicht schlecht aber wenn die
andere person sowieso halt irgendwas
vertuschen will
dann weiß ich nicht ob so viel bringen
sie zu fragen so verdutzt so gerade was
weil eine person ein hätte sich sagen
wollen von sich aus oder so wissen was
mein letzter von anfangs schon gesagt
egal wie es wieder weg bnd baby ist
wieder weg läuft also falls ja jetzt
fragt was mit bnd wie meine ich arbeite
in dem ersten video wo sie wohl sie auch
schon der fremde ihr tipps gegeben hat
also weiß komplett geflecht von den
methoden die sie da angewandt hatten wir
sogar dienste rinnert eben geheimdienst
wie der bnd also der
bundesnachrichtendienst der deutsche
geheimdienst auf dachte ich idiot das
baby sich mit der rein inhaltlichen
aussage ja ich bin fremdgegangen nein
ich bin nicht fremdgegangen
zufriedengeben müssen
falsch gedacht also von mir das alles
ist natürlich null taktik man lässt den
anderen sprechen um seine körpersprache
mit hilfe der neuesten erkenntnisse der
psychotherapie zu analysieren
die studie bewiesen dass ich sage jetzt
ausschließlich neueste erkenntnisse der
psychotherapie und blieb und ein pony
studie eine studie die gal will ich es
einfach auf wissenschaftlicher basis
unterwegs bei den tipps es ist zu wenig
und das ganze ist zu witzig alte das ist
zu witzig sie habe vorzustellen das ist
die gleiche baby also halt doch nicht
und natürlich aber die heute hat einfach
so eine youtube ikone bedeutet ist so
wahrscheinlich auch vorbild für voll für
die junge mütter in deutschland soll es
aber zu fall
es ist wirklich ist dieses
geheimdienstleute es ist dieses
geheimdienst level und ganz ehrlich ich
frage mich an der stelle auf welcher
wave ist bibi heute wenn sie vor über
acht jahren schon auf der geheimdienst
wissenschaftliche studien zu rate ziehen
vom fremdgeh taktiken zu erkennen wave
war der wusste wo ist sie dann heute
es ist acht jahre vergangen also wenn
sich vor acht jahren schon so krass weil
es die heute safeconsole weltherrschaft
leute es ist es ist wirklich schwer es
ist schwer für alle von euch da draußen
die sich denken okay in der beziehung
muss man ganz ehrlich auch mal in einer
anderen seitensprung einbauen ich
brauche meinen persönlichen gefühle so
geht es nicht es ist selbstverständlich
nicht heute aber alle von euch da
draußen die sich noch in sicherheit
gewähnt haben die das erste video von
baby gesehen haben sich gedacht haben
so jetzt kann ich einmal meine alte oder
meinen alten komplett waren
aber jetzt gehe ich mal richtig ab seid
gewarnt sagt gewarnt die gegenseite ist
auch informiert von beelen www.spielen
dem baby wie gesagt auch nicht abwertend
gemeint sondern einfach so kompliment
weil sie so krasse taktiken
kann es sein wenn man ihn direkt drauf
anspricht also dann eine vorformulierte
ausgedachte antwort okay okay ja dass
das für mich irgendwie nicht so sehr die
anderen tipps waren crazy aber das wird
nicht so sehr
also ich mein baby wie soll das konkret
vorstellen so sagst du jemanden so
martin gibt's zu gehst du mir fremd und
er soll also nach aktuellen
erkenntnissen des
bundesnachrichtendienstes der verbindung
mit dem israelischen geheimdienste
dessen mosshart kann ich an dieser
stelle zugegeben dass ich mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht fremd gegangen
bin aber nicht absichtlich falsch
verstehen aber also wenn eine person
glücklicher ist als sonst ist das ist es
ein indiz für einen seitensprung
das hat sie so gemeint oder als ich will
es wirklich nicht absolut falsch
versteht aber setzt auch so gemeint hat
sich so gemeint ich glaube schon okay
alles klar
gut na dann leute ihr wisst ihr bescheid
wenn eines tages ein partner aufwacht
und eigentlich seid ihr beide sehr
deprimiert die menschen seit jeden tag
schlecht drauf und eines tages wacht der
drecksack auf und hat einfach ein
lächeln im gesicht
dann wisst ihr malaga der typ geht fremd
ok ja muss ich sagen bin ich bei ihr ja
also wenn wenn euer freund oder freundin
auf einmal anfängt drei abende die woche
so ist in den nächsten morgen hinein
cricket zu spielen oder wahlweise auch
zu protokoll gibt dass er oder sie im
sommer schlittschuhlaufen geht dann
würde ich natürlich schon besten
vorsichtig sein
jetzt bereite ich glaube dass
bibi und schubia ein kunde sehr positive
beziehung haben und das mit sicherheit
in allen beiden was gut läuft aber nur
für den fall dass irgendwie dass
irgendjemand der jemals mit beginn der
beziehung ist oder war etwas im schilde
geführt hat oder aktuell führt ist diese
person wirklich kapital
okay okay
sollte der partner auf einmal übermäßige
hygiene wandel an den tag legen und die
ehemals [ __ ] die er oder sie war
nicht mehr sein dann wisst ihr geht
fremd so was macht also ich muss sagen
leute das war wieder zu bild wie gesagt
dass videos in einer beschreibung
verlinkt check hier ein für euch
vorgeschlagen das video ab abonniert
hier oben meinen kanal und geht mir
nicht fremd abonniert keine andere
youtube-kanäle ok eine sache noch leute
schreibt man in die kommentare wenn ihr
wollt die krasseste fremdgeht story die
in ihrem leben jemals gehört hat man
leicht die hoch wenn ihre kasse in den
kommentaren findet ich bin in der
strauss macht's gut